The fundamental currency
of our universe is energy.
It lights our homes, grows our
food, powers our computers.
We can get it lots of ways.
Burning fossil fuels,
splitting atoms or sunlight
striking photo of all tags,
but there's a downside to everything.
Fossil fuels are extremely toxic.
Nuclear waste as well.
Nuclear waste,
and there are not enough batteries to
store sunlight for cloudy days yet,
and yet the sun seems to have
virtually limitless free energy.
Is there a way we could build a
sun on earth? Can we bottle a star?
The Sun shines because of nuclear fusion.
In a nutshell,
fusion is a thermo nuclear process,
meaning that the ingredients
have to be incredibly hot,
so hot that the atoms are stripped
of their electrons making a plasma.
When Nuclei and electrons
bounce around freely,
since nuclei are all positively charged,
they repel each other.
In order to overcome this repulsion,
the particles have to be going very,
very fast. In this context,
very fast means that very hot,
millions of degrees stars cheat
to reach these temperatures.
They are so massive that
the pressure in there,
because that generates the
heats to squeeze the nuclei
together until they merge
and fuse creating heavier nuclei
and releasing energy in the process.
It is this energy release that scientists
hope to harness in a new generation of
powerplant the fusion reactor on earth.
It's not feasible to use this,
a brute force method to create fusion.
So if we wanted to build a react to
that generates energy from fusion,
we have to get clever.
To date,
scientists have invented two ways of
making plasmas hot enough to fuse.
The first type of reactor uses a
magnetic field to squeeze a plasma in a
doughnut shaped chamber where
the reactions take place.
These magnetic confinement
reactors such as the ite,
our reactor in France use super conducting
electromagnets cooled with liquid
helium to within a few degrees of absolute
zero meaning they host some of the
biggest temperature gradients
in the known universe.
The second type called inertial
confinement uses pulses from super powered
lasers to hit the surface of a palace,
a fuel imploding.
It briefly making the feel hot
and dense enough to fuse. In fact,
one of the most powerful lasers in the
world is used for fusion experiments at
the national ignition facility in the u
s these experiments and others like them
around the world are
today just experiments.
Scientists are still
developing the technology
and although they can
achieve fusion right now,
it costs more energy to do the
experiments than they produce infusion.
The technology has a long way to go before
it's commercially viable and maybe it
never will be.
It might just be impossible to make a
viable fusion reactor on earth bars if
against that it will be sell efficient.
There's a single glass of seawater could
be used to produce as much energy as
burning a barrel of oil
with no waste to speak of.
This is because fusion reactors would
use hydrogen or helium as fuel and
seawater is loaded with hydrogen,
but not just any hydrogen.
We'll do specific isotopes with extra
neutrons called Deuterium and tritium are
needed to make the right reactions.
Deuterium is stable and can be
found in abundance. In Sea water,
though tritium is a bit trickier,
it's radioactive and there may only
be 20 kilograms of is in the world,
mostly in nuclear warheads,
which makes it incredibly expensive,
so we may need another fusion buddy
for deuterium instead of tritium.
Helium three an isotope of helium
might be a great substitute.
Unfortunately,
it's also incredibly rare on earth,
but here the moon might have the
answer over billions of years,
the soda wind may have built up a huge
deposits of helium three on the moon.
Instead of making helium
three we can minus.
If we could set the lunar dust for helium,
we'd have enough fuel to power the
entire world for thousands of years.
One more argument for establishing a moon
base if you weren't convinced already.
Okay. Maybe you think building a mini
son still sounds kind of dangerous,
but they'd actually be much safer
than most other types of power plant.
A fusion reactor is not
like a nuclear plant,
which can melt down catastrophic
catastrophically if the
confinement failed than
the plasma would expand and cool and
the reaction would stop put simply.
It's not a bomb.
The release of radioactive fueled light
tritium could pose a threat to the
environment. Tritium could bond with
oxygen making radioactive water,
which could be dangerous as it seeps
into the environment. Fortunately,
there's no more than a few grams
of tritium end use at a given time,
so a leak would be quickly diluted.
So we've just told you that there's
nearly unlimited energy to be had at no
expense to the environment in
something as simple as water.
So what's the catch cost?
We simply don't know if fusion power
will ever be commercially viable.
Even if they work,
they might be too expensive to ever build.
The main drawback is that
it's unproven technology.
It's a $10 billion gamble and that money
might be better spent on other clean
energy that's already proven itself.
Maybe we should cut our losses or maybe
when the payoff is unlimited clean
energy for everyone,
it might be worth the risk
videos.
Like this one,
take hundreds of hours to make and I
made possible by your contributions on
patrion.com if you want to
learn more about global energy,
here's a playlist about nuclear energy,
fracking and soda power.
Let us know in the comments if there
are other technologies you want us to
explain.